and Chris I want to go back to the
workout video because you weren't nearly
as impressed as the Dolphins apparently
were by what to a Tonga valo did what
gives their reconcile that for me well
yeah I mean you know one I wasn't
impressed cuz I didn't sit there and go
oh my gosh whoa he's so quick whoa look
at the ball explode out of his hands you
know there was a bunch of wobbly throws
things like that that's where I looked
at it yes
it doesn't matter Mike this is who they
wanted to take that they just wanted to
see a little glimmer of hope to justify
that they wanted this guy you know I we
had heard you know back when the seeds
of regular season ended that they loved
Tula we know that now it sounded like
the owner loved Joe borough as well and
that conversation was going on but if it
wasn't going to be borough
I think Miami had her I said on to all
along they obviously didn't love the
prospect of what Justin Herbert could
bring to their football team and Brian
Flores come in from New England which
has a lot of carryover from Alabama I'm
sure he likes a lot of those qualities
that tua can bring from Alabama to his
football team so yeah I was not sitting
there overly impressed from that workout
nor you know like like Brian Flores says
it's just a 9 minute workout video it
doesn't really do much for you but it
does when you're a team that's going oh
we really want to take a franchise
quarterback but we don't like this just
an uber kid what do we do from here we
really like this to a guy but there's
these injuries outlook they're a you see
he throws he can move yeah ok good
doctors he's good ok as good guys were
drafted him at number 5 I mean that's
all they needed they just needed a
little a little nudge to show that he
was healthy and and and Armando Salguero
released the media report that the
Dolphins doctors are fine you know that
was all a process of Miami trying to
make the fan base and the organization
that everybody feel warm and cozy about
the the prospects of dropping to it
confirmation bias is the dynamic that
you are illustrating in your comments
there Chris because a lot of this
happens in the draft process you come
into it as an evaluator with an idea of
what you want to do so what do you do
you look for things that support what
you already want to do and you find a
way to minimize downplay or flat out
ignore if necessary anything out there
that cuts against what it is that you
already want to do whether you already
like a guy whether you already don't
like a guy this is human nature and I
think the best organizations and I'm not
saying that dolphins got it wrong here
but the best organizations know how to
rise above confirmation bias and
continue to be objective and understand
up until the very end they're not locked
into a guy until they put the name on
the card and they did try to move up to
get Joe Borough we don't know what they
offered and I was trying to think Chris
of a circumstance where it would get out
what the Dolphins ultimately put on the
table the Dolphins have no reason to
undermine their faith into a Tonga bylaw
right now so they've got no reason to
leak or admit what they offered right
the bengals have no reason to say what
we could have had other than jobber oh i
think the only way it would ever come
out is if borough is just spectacular
out of the gates clear-cut future
hall-of-famer Toa ends up stinking maybe
the bengals at that point will be
tempted to say hey look here's what we
turned down we knew what we were doing
in not giving anyone else the chance to
get Joe Borough we knew to say no can
you believe we said no to this what we
knew to tell Miami sorry you can stick
it even though they offered us all that
stuff to come get Joe borough well yeah
I mean I
you're probably right you're probably
well here at then well it is just
justify that yeah for Miami to be able
to sell their fan base hey we tried to
get this guy we knew he was going to be
special we offered it to them but hey
this to a conversation is very
interesting I'm really interested to see
where it goes this year how healthy is
ready to go again
I really like the person it's my least
favorite thing of the year doing draft
evals because it's not about the kid
it's it's truly just you know business
here we're just talking about what he's
done on the field and I know he has a
lot of great attributes I do and there's
things I like it
game but I'm also concerned that he's
being overdrafted as you know one
because I think he's getting the credit
for which is the Alabama machine right
that hey Alabama's offense was it was
really good once he got hurt they throw
up like almost 40 points against Auburn
they blew out Michigan who had one of
the better defenses in football you know
so I feel like we're in this era of
doing this and I think really but to uh
I worry about that too that was my
concern I wasn't blown away by what I
saw in the film Mike and the other thing
that always jumps out to me where I do
feel like he's being over drafted on
intangibles too much you know when I
hear Brian Flores and other people talk
about to it the first things that are
out of his mouth or they're usually not
about what he does on the field it's
always he's a great leader he's a winner
he's tough I don't like hearing that
when it's my top five pick I want to
hear he's got a rocket right arm he can
move around the pocket and make people
miss and extend plays and you know that
to me when you start drafting a ton
tangibles is a little risky as my point
and that's where I just feel like the
little risky batula will see you where
it goes if I'm wrong you know I'll say
I'm wrong when that time guns and you
don't have to make apologies for making
an objective assess what I do
why that's what the sport is premise tap
on identifying the best players and
putting them on the field and putting
the players who aren't the best players
on the bench or passing over them in
round one or round two and drafting them
in round three I mean for a guy who was
a third round pick who thinks he should
have been a first-round pick you should
be more of a jerk when it comes dropping
guys down the board cuz it happened to
you well it's one of those things where
I feel like in our business sometimes
when you say something about the player
professionally they think it carries
over to the personal life - and they
think oh he doesn't like him he hates
that guy and I want to make no I'm sorry
I'm delicate about that but yes my
football evaluation to your point yes
I'll stand
I'll stand strong with that and that is
what I believe the reality is no amount
of caveats or tiptoes by you is going to
change the fact that if you say
something that someone doesn't like on
Merritt about a player with
yeah crossing into the line of the
personal they're still gonna think you
hate him you don't like him so Chris
let's end with this why do you hate to a
tongue of Eylau I don't hate him sorry
he's a good guy I just have my dad my
bottom as a football player
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports